gut dann willkommen zur heutigen sitzung
wir haben uns heute diesen netten herrn
hier vorgenommen als jemand von ihnen
wieder heißt arthur schopenhauer und wir
werden von ihm diese schrift über die
vierfach wurzel des satzes vom zu
reichen grunde lesen die war meines
wissens seine dissertation
aber der hat sie dann auch ein paar mal
überarbeitet also diese version die wir
aus der wir heute aus zu gelesen die ist
nicht die originalversion und jetzt
möchte ich zur zur einstimmung eine
kurze anekdote ihn verlesen
der 43 jährige aber schon mauer war pum
die 17-jährige flora weiß bei einer kahn
party auf einem berliner see reicht er
dem mädchen weintrauben und die arme
flora sie berichtet ich wollte sie aber
nicht haben mir war es eklig weil der
olle schopenhauer sie angefasst hat und
da lese ich sie so ganz sagte hinter mir
ins wasser bleiben also schopenhauer
hatte bei den frauen nicht so viel
erfolg
deswegen hatte auch ganz üble schriften
über sie verfasst können sie mal googeln
aber die sollen nicht gegenstand unseres
seminars sein sollen wir wollen uns hier
ganz sachlich mit seiner theorie des
grundes und kausalität befassen aber
schopenhauer hat immer auch ganz kuriose
dinge geschrieben shopmacher war eben
ein exzentriker und man sieht nach kant
dass ich nach immanuel kants philosophie
die wir in der letzten sitzung mehr
behandelt haben dass ich das in
entwicklung ereignet die auch sehr offen
ist für andere einflüsse also gerade bei
arthur schopenhauer sieht man dass es
sich sehr öffnet gegenüber der indischen
philosophie die medien sind wir ihn ganz
wichtig in dieser welt als wille und
vorstellung da spielen diese indischen
gedanken eine große rolle
er öffnet sich auch für literatur
wir werden jetzt hier sehen in diesen
zitaten die wir jetzt behandeln werden
heute dass auch der wolfgang goethe
waren wolfgang goethe eine rolle spielt
sie wissen schopenhauer ist in danzig
geboren und ist dann aber recht bald
dann auch nach weimar immer wieder
gekommen wo seine mutter auch dann war
und wo er mit denen weimarer klassikern
in kontakt kamen darunter auch goethe
und also er ist sozusagen auch sehr
offen für andere bereiche und das macht
ihn interessant das macht ihn aber auch
problematisch weil er weil man ihnen
vielleicht dann noch stärker
rekonstruieren muss als es bei kanzler
sowie der fall ist aber es ist eine
zentrale schrift ich hatte sie vorher
auch noch nicht studiert und jetzt nutze
ich dieses seminars nämlich zum anlass
auch auf bitten eines teilnehmers irrt
mal hier ein paar zitate noch zu bringen
bevor wir dann der nächsten sitzung eben
mit stärker systematisch ausgerichteten
texten uns befassen werden die dann also
wesentlich jünger sind das ist jetzt der
letzte der historischen oppositionelle
zu der historischen position die wir
heute gemeinsam lesen wollen jetzt haben
wir also drei fragen also was versteht
schopenhauer und dem satz von
zureichenden gründen welche bedeutung
hat nach schopenhauer der satz vom
zureichenden grunde
und wie verhält sich sein
qualitätsbegriff zudem liegt bei
immanuel kant sie wissen also
schopenhauer war ganz stark von kann
beeinflusst und auch beeindruckt das mag
auch damit zusammenhängen dass er eben
aus einer ähnlichen regionen stammt also
königsberg und danzig sind ja nicht so
weit voneinander entfernt und man muss
dazu sagen dass eben danzig als eine
ostseestadt immer auch eben auch wie
königsberg im regen austausch zu anderen
kulturnationen stand wie zb england weil
über den handel den ostsee handel
sehr viele ideen eben auch nach ins
damalige deutschland kamen und zwar
darüber anerkannt eben von david hume
wohl erfahren über diesen ostsee gute
und auch schopenhauer hat durch dieses
internationale lage von danzig eben sehr
viele anregungen bekommen ist jetzt
natürlich nur ideengeschichtliche
kontext sie spielen jetzt für die
beurteilung seiner systematischen
theorie natürlich nicht so eine große
rolle aber einmal den hintergrund zu
wissen kann nicht schaden
und jetzt gehen wir mal gleich ins
zweite kapitel wo er sagt wo er von
einer übersicht des hauptsächlich ssten
so bisher über den satz vom zureichenden
grund geleert worden sein das spricht
als vom wichtigsten hauptsächlich ssten
was bisher über den satz von zureichend
grund geleert worden ist da geht es also
trumpf und jetzt sagt er hier also
schätzt natürlich immer an gekannt sehr
der ist für ihn ein held unter anderem
aber auch natürlich gehörte also sehr
wichtige philosophen für ihn er sagt
erkannt mit dem eine welt periode in der
philosophie anhebt hat auch auf die
logik allen wohltätigen einfluss gehabt
er bewirkt eine bestimmte hre
absonderung der look von der trans
dental philosophie oder bisherigen
metaphysik grundsatz vom zureichenden
grunde lässt kann jedoch in beiden
aufträgen in der logik die seinen namen
führt nimmt er auf seine 73 den satz das
kriterium der äußeren logischen wahrheit
oder der rationalität die erkenntnis auf
welchem die wirklichkeit erkenntnis
beruht in der trans zentralen logik aber
lässt den satz als prinzip der
kausalität auftreten und beweist in
sogar als solches von ich seine swords
ausführlicher reden wird obgleich also
den unterschied an erkennt bestimmte
doch seine aussage nicht genau nach
selbigen wie ich am ende dieser
abhandlung zeigen werde und gibt dadurch
zu dunkelheiten und missverständnissen
anlass also wie bei sehr vielen
philosophen ist es so er knüpft an sie
knüpfen anderen bereits bestehende
diesen bestehenden theorien und
versuchen die dann an manchen stellen zu
verbessern also da sagt ja immer da ist
irgendwas dunkel und es gibt
missverständnisse und die möchte jetzt
schopenhauer nach eigenem bekunden hier
löste zwar hier aber zwei wichtige
begriffe oder zwei wichtige wendungen
wir haben einmal eine transzendentale
logik hier und wir haben noch die bloße
logik was kann jetzt damit gemeint sein
also nach kant also wir haben die logik
schreibt er natürlich nicht also wir
haben die logik und die transzendentale
logik was ist der unterschied zwischen
beiden wissen sie dass zwischen logik
dass falls mal als als hintergrund
zwischen der logik und einer trans
zentralen logica
genau aufzeigen
möglichkeit dass geschlossen
ja also das geht glaube ich in die
richtige richtung
also es ist jedenfalls noch stärker auch
mit der erkenntnistheorie verbunden also
bekannt gibt es ja diese zwei bereiche
das logische und das ist sozusagen das
analytische das analytische und das
trans zentrale ist verkannt dass
synthetische ich glaube das wäre auch
noch eine gute unterscheidung also trans
zentrale philosophie ist nach kann immer
etwas wie sie richtig sagen was die
bedingung der möglichkeit uns erkenntnis
betrifft weil es also die
grundstrukturen unseres wahrnehmens
erkennens wie anbelangt und kant
unterscheidet der seine kritik der
reinen vernunft eine transzendenz tätig
und eine transzendentale lockt die sind
die sinnlichkeit und sinnlichkeit eben
anders damals verstanden wurde als heute
heute ist etwas sinnlich wenn es
erotisch ist oder dem engen bereich
betrachtet wird und damals war
sinnlichkeit eben viel weiter damals
fiel unter sinnlichkeit die ganze
wahrnehmung die sinneswahrnehmung als
ästhetik ist die wahrnehmungs lehre
einigt als astana griechisch heißt
einfach nur wahrnehmen
unsere sinne und die trans zentrale
ästhetik befasst sich eben dann mit den
bedingungen der möglichkeit unserer
wahrnehmung und da sind eben ganz
zentral raum und zeit von bedeutung also
wir können überhaupt nur wahrnehmung
haben wenn wir in raum und zeit
wahrnehmen und das ist also ein teil der
eben die wahrnehmung betrifft auch die
sinnes daten letztendlich diese x10 die
ich ihnen hier hin gemalt hatte ich
hatte da so ein paar rahmungen das
letzte mal oder auch das vorletzte mal
hier an die wand an die tafel gezeichnet
und man könnte sagen die transzendentale
ist tätig betrifft die inneren rahmen
und die inneren punkte dieser erkenntnis
nämlich die x10
die sinus daten also zb rot eindruck
perzeption nach der video alle alle
perzeption betrifft die trans zentrale
ästhetik und auch noch die rahmung des
raumes und der zeit das sind alles teile
die die trans zentrale ästhetik
betreffen und jetzt gibt es aber auch
noch andere rahmungen haben wir gesehen
hat nämlich zum beispiel die rahmung der
substanz die rahmung der kausalität und
natürlich noch die rahmung des lcds was
alles um greift und diese rahmungen der
kausalität und die rahmung der substanz
zum beispiel die gehören nicht mehr so
franz endt ästhetik sondern zu trans
zentralen logik also die ganzen
verstandes kategorien das was david hume
in der ästhetik suchen wollte nämlich
kausalität und dort nicht finden konnte
das verlagert kann in die tanz zentrale
logik und also lage ist die sind die
verstandes tätigkeiten die trans
zentralen verstandes tätigkeiten oder
gibt es die trans en halogen- es gibt
eben visier seien auch die logik als das
ist die traditionelle logica und für
beides erkannt muss der satz nach
schopenhauer gibt es einen satz von wohl
vom zureichenden grund als der der tritt
in beiden auf was hat denn der satz von
zureichende grund eigentlich
was ist in der zu erreichende grund vom
ersten eindruck wenn sie einfach mal
sagen sollten was das ist genauso sagen
jetzt einzureichen und übersetzt sie
jetzt mit hinreichend genau also alles
muss einen grund haben könnte man auch
sagen das ist einfach geschieht alles
was geschieht muss einen grund haben das
ist geschieht und das ist geschieht das
ist das zu erreichende oder das
hinreichend wie auch immer das ist eben
überhaupt geschieht das ist ein grund
gibt von dem man sagt das war der grund
von dem das war irgendwie das auslösende
moment das begründen den moment das ist
alles einen grund haben muss
wie könnt ihr jetzt in der logik ein
solcher kunden eine rolle spielen ein
bisschen idee
also das kann
jeder trage
nicht nur vor
[Musik]
so könnte man es sieht also jetzt recht
formal betrachtet nur dann würde dann
würden sie sagen dass dann in der logik
so was wie kausalitäten rolle spielen
würde nicht gelten
genau das ist also schon mal gut dass
wir diesen unterschied fest macht also
der begriff der kausalität spielt
offenbar nur in der transzendentalen
logischen rolle aber nicht in der logik
in der reinen logik wenn sie den herrn
leitgeb fragen unseren logiker hier
ob in der logischen ableitungen ob dort
also formal logisch ob davon kausalität
die rede ist würde das wahrscheinlich
von einem ich habe jetzt nicht gefragt
aber der begriff der kausalität würde
eher sagen wozu gehört er der gehört
nicht zur logik sondern wozu gehört der
begriff die kausalität welche disziplin
gehört der in der philosophie der
qualitätsbegriff wenn sie mal schauen
der seminar ankündigung gibt es immer so
kategorisierung also wo ich das jetzt
eingeteilt habe diese seminarthema ich
habe es zum beispiel nicht zu
sprachphilosophie genommen ich habe es
aber zu erkenntnistheorie genommen und
ich habe es noch zu etwas anderem
genommen ich habe es nicht zu logik ich
habe etwas anderen genommen welchen
bereich der philosophie gehört die frage
nach der kausalität
genau metaphysik und unterlassen
metaphysische fragen und kant analysiert
die traditionelle metaphysik und
ontologien im rahmen seiner
transzendentalen philosophie oder noch
genauer im rahmen sei trans zentralen
logik also substanz ist verkannt nichts
mehr was eigentlich technologie betrifft
im sinne eines eines realismus ist also
die substanz unabhängig von uns als
erkennen dem subjekt vor uns steht wie
der tisch der steht da einfach und er
steht unabhängig von unseren bedingungen
erkenntnis dort sondern kann sagt nein
wir müssen vor vormals metaphysisch
begriffe und zwar jetzt der metaphysiker
general ist dann muss man doch
unterscheiden es gibt die metaphysik
spezialist wir sind sie von werfen was
die handel die spezielle mit der physik
von welchen gegenständen oder themen die
handelt wissen sie noch zum beispiel
spezielle metaphysik hat die spezielle
handelt von gott von der seele
von solchen ganz hohen dingen sage jetzt
mal der fragestellungen also seele dass
dann die rationale psychologie dann gibt
es noch die rationale theologie dass die
frage noch gut an gibt es auch die
rationale kosmologie sie fragen nach der
welt weltseele gott das sind themen der
nationalen also der metaphysik
spezialist der speziellen metaphysik
also die ganz konkrete fragestellung hat
und zwar ganz erhabene gegenstände und
dann gibt es auch die generelle
metaphysiker generals und die
metaphysiker general ist fragt einfach
nachdem sein denn all seinen details zum
beispiel nach substanzen nach dem stuhl
wie ist der stuhl fast wie muss man so
ein stuhl denken das heißt die ganzen
sachen auch kausalität würde ich jetzt
mal zu metaphysiker generale szene
substantially tät das sind alles dinge
die kann dann im in seiner
transzendentalen logik
die ganzen verstandes kategorien einheit
vielheit kausalität substantially tät
die holten die trans zentrale logik
hinein und die metaphysiker spezialist
also welt selig gott die behandelt kant
nicht in seiner transzendentalen logik
sondern wissen sie in welchem bereich
seiner kritik der reinen vernunft
handelt ja genau wir hatten auch noch
eine dialektik trans anteile dialektik
ist die lehre vom schein eigentlich das
ist also da wo uns die vernunft täuscht
hatte die vernunft ist da sehr
problematisch in diesen bereichen
das sind alte diese frage nach dem
ersten und letzten gibt es eine
unsterblichkeit der seele gibt es einen
ersten anfang der welt ist die frage
nach der nationalen kosmologie und gibt
es ein höchstes wesen ist die frage nach
gott diese fragen das erkannt die sind
sehr problematisch in unserer vernunft
angelegt und deswegen müssen wir sie
sehr kritisch betrachten während andere
begriffe wie kausalität substantially
tät nicht so problematisch sind und die
sind ihr in der trans zentralen logik
angesiedelt also wenn wir von logik
sprechen nur also hier das hier
diese logik hier und er kann spricht da
würde kann nicht von kausalität reden
dh der satz von zureichend grunde ist im
grunde genannt noch viel basala als die
frage nach der kausalität es noch viel
grundsätzlicher
normal weiter noch ist zu erwähnen dass
man mehrmals vergeblich versucht hat den
satz zu weißem grund überhaupt beweisen
meist ohne genau zu bestimmen in welcher
bedeutung man ihn nahm wolf muss man
eigentlich mit zwei aufschreiben
christian wolf in der anthologie § 70
welchen beweis baumgarten es ist auch so
vor kann tische aufklärer in der
metaphysik 783 wiederholt es wäre
überflüssig ihn auch hier zu wiederholen
und zu überlegen da ist in die augen
fällt dass er auf einem wortspiel beruht
plattner in den aphorismen jakob in der
logik und metaphysik haben andere
beweise versucht in denen der zirkel
sehr weit zu erkennen ist sehr leicht zu
erkennen ist von kants beweis soll wie
gesagt weiter unten geredet werden da
ich durch diese abhandlung die
verschiedenen gesetze unseres erkenntnis
vermögens deren gemeinschaftliche
ausdruck der satzung zu reiten grund ist
aufweisen aufzuweisen hoffe so wird sich
von selbst ergeben dass der satz
überhaupt nicht zu beweisen ist und von
allen jenen beweisen mit ausnahme
natürlich dass kantischen die in dem an
ganz anderen sinne ist gilt was
aristoteles sagt es ist jetzt leider
schlecht aus gekommen
in der metaphysik denn jeder beweis ist
die zurückführung des zweifelhaften auf
ein anerkanntes und werden wir von
diesem was auch sei immer wieder ein
beweis fordern zu werden wir zuletzt auf
gewisse sätze geraten die bedingungen
alles denkens und erkennen sind ja aus
deren anwendung alles denken und
erkennen steht sodass gewissheit nichts
ist als übereinstimmung mit ihnen
folglich ihre eigene gewissheit nicht
wieder aus anderen setzen erhellen kann
jetzt möchte ich an sie eine rückfrage
stellen warum sagt jetzt schopenhauer
offensichtlich in diesem zitat dass
jeder versucht so interpretiere ich
jetzt in den satz des zu reichen grundes
zu beweisen so cool er ist der einzige
ist also hier spricht er
überlegen sie mal warum ist der schiere
versuchen den satz von zu reichen grunde
als das alles einen grund haben muss hat
sie beweisen warum ist der eigentlich
vergeblich oder eigentlich zurück
ja
davon aus
jedes ding was geschieht da ist es
die allererste ursache zuzumuten
ok so könnte man es sehen ja dass man
also immer wieder zurück verwiesen wird
ok oder der meint erst hier ist feiner
meldung ja hatte sich jemand gemeldet
bitte was haben wir falsch noch größeres
problem sehen uns war das rein logisch
unmöglich ist wer bist du weißt
bedeutete das zu begründen und schon
auch den satz
im grunde nichts zu rufen kann man
nichts gründen also auch kein komisches
nicht möglich muss jeden kunden
auf der grundsatz der gründe und den
fall deswegen kann man begründen oder
mieten
genau also ich glaube so ist es zu
verstehen also beweisen heißt eigentlich
immer schon versuchen wollen zu
begründen in diesem sinne und setzten
praktisch voraus jetzt immer schon
voraus die geltung des satzes des
zureichend grundes werden wir einen
beweis anstrengen wollen setzen wir das
schon voraus also wir können gar nicht
anders denken als den satz vom zu
reichen gründe anzunehmen als bestehend
selbst wenn wir beweisen also die
tatsache dass wir beweisen wollen oder
uns ein beweis vornehm zeigt schon dass
die implizit den satz von zur einen
grund anerkannt haben und wenn wir jetzt
damit den satz und sogar im grunde
beweisen wollen mit dem satzes zu
reichen kunden dann beginnen wir
eigentlich ein zirkelschluss also wir
setzen das heraus was wir erst beweisen
wollen ja das ist so ein bisschen diese
problematik und das ist ja eigentlich
ziemlich clever jetzt mal gedacht na
also der adressat ist zu rechnen grundes
muss offensichtlich auf einer anderen
ebene angesiedelt sein als es ein
normale gegenstände sind oder auch
normale erkenntnissen sind
man könnte sagen der satz es zu wahren
grundes ist so was wie ein trans
zentrales prinzip also wir können sagen
die bedingung der möglichkeit um
überhaupt logik zu betreiben und um
überhaupt auch erkenntnis betreiben zu
können ohne diesen satz können wir das
gar nicht tun oder wie sehen sie das
ich finde es doch
schwer zu sagen dass die qualität nur
eine art das hat das unbegründet weil
man sie deswegen auch rentierlich
beweisen kann und ihre trotzdem annehmen
mussten von ist die jungs problemen zu
sagen also ein emotionslos ist was auch
sein weil es eben schon in den
unionsregierten gründung genau und was
ist noch ein vorteil wenn man das ganze
jetzt also auf dem gemeinsamen
grundhafte gemeinsame wurzeln da geht es
mir hier nochmal zurück als ich er geht
auf eine wurzel es ist eine vierfache
wurzel aber es eine wurzel der satz von
zugrunde was es noch einen vorteil ein
vorteil ist wie mir scheint auch noch
der dass er nämlich logik und
erkenntnistheorie oder dran zentral
philosophie was eben auch noch
metaphysik ist in einem einzelnen
prinzip fundieren kann also er kann
zeigen mit dem satz ist so eine grundes
haben wir die basis von logik von
erkenntnistheorie und von metaphysik bei
kant fallen der metaphysik und
erkenntnistheorie zusammen könnte man
sagen
in dieser trans and a logik aber das
heißt er geht noch eine stufe tiefer als
kann das ist natürlich auch ein
hochgradig spekulatives unternehmen muss
man sagen hier mit beginnt eben auch die
phase des sogenannten deutschen
idealismus das heißt sie beginnt ja doch
mit dem jungen schopenhauer durchaus
aber es gab natürlich noch andere viele
denker die versucht haben kannst theorie
nochmal eine stufe tiefer zu denken noch
mal tief kommentiert denken ja also da
wo sie eben vielheit haben da wo sie mit
logik haben und wo sie eine
transzendentale logik haben da liegt es
nahe das sagen ja was ist in der
gemeinsame grund
von beiden wo sie viel geld haben wollen
sie immer einheit haben das natürlich
auch so eine eigenart des satzes von
suchen im grunde das immer einen grund
gibt es spricht natürlich von einer
vierfachen wurzeln
das müssen wir uns alle mal ein bisschen
genauer vorstellen das hat er jetzt auch
eine metapher die vierfache wurzeln wie
man die verstehen kann
also das ist glaube ich ziemlich clever
dass man also sagt beweist diese
skulptur im grunde kann man gar nicht
machen weil wir indem wir beweisen dass
schon voraussetzt und zwar überlegen sie
mal welches argument in der geschichte
der philosophie erinnert sich denn da
erinnert sie dass diese diese struktur
des zu gleichen grund ist dass wir ihm
beweisen den satz schon zu grunde legen
und ihn damit fast schon beweisen also
durch das beweisen wir beweisen einsatz
von zugleich im grunde nicht indem wir
ihnen beweisen können
das sind indem wir einfach den versucht
unternehmen zu beweisen also mir
beweisen die nicht direkt aber wir legen
ihn ein
es ist sowas performativ ist als in dem
etwas tun nämlich weiß anspringen
bestätigen wir den inhalt also die form
bestätigt den inhalt das ist ganz clever
also performativ könnte man sagen
überlegen sie mal in der geschichte der
philosophie wo gibt es das noch so ein
ähnliches argument klassiker
ja ja dieses gut sein mit dem guten das
geht in seine richtung aber überlegen
sie mal mit dem performative mit dem
performative gibt es noch einen ganz
großen philosophen denen sie alle kennen
das ist der klassiker can't kennen sie
noch so ein ähnliches argument aufzeigen
wo es auch darum geht dass man
eigentlich in einer tätigkeit ist schon
etwas belebt was man durch die tätigkeit
gerade herausfinden möchte das glaube
ich auch als bei descartes sage ich
denke also dieses 2 verzweifle und in
dem ich zweifle bin ich ja schon also in
dem ich praktisch alle sind frage stelle
beweise ich gerade dass nicht alles in
frage gestellt werden kann weil immer ja
noch in frage gestellt werden kann
das hat sie eine ganz ähnliche struktur
ist nicht genau das selbe da müsste man
unterscheiden
aber es geht es eine ähnliche richtung
also wir haben jetzt ein zug von
schopenhauer fest kennengelernt schon
der ihn in eine spekulative ecke
verortet und jetzt geht es zum dritten
kapitel von der unzulänglichkeit der
bisherigen darstellung und end to end
und entwurf zu einer 9
aus dem vorigen kapitel aus der im
folgenden kapitel geben übersicht ergibt
sich als allgemeines resultat dass man
obwohl erst allmählich und nicht ohne
öfter von neun verwechselungen und
fehlgriffe zu geraten
zwei anwendungen des satzes von zu
reichen grunde unterschieden hat die
eine auf urteile die um wahr zu sein im
ein grund die andere auf veränderungen
reale objekte die immer eine ursache
haben müssen wir sehen dass in beiden
fällen der sei zwar zu gleichen grund
zur frage warum richtig welche
eigenschaft im wesentlichen ihm
wesentlich ist allein sind unter jenen
beiden verhältnissen alle fälle
begriffen in denen wir warum zu fragen
berechtigt sind wenn ich frage warum
sind in diesem triangel diesem dreieck
die drei seiten gleich ist die antwort
weil die drei winkel gleich sind ist nun
die gleichheit der winkel ursache der
gleichheit der seiten nein denn hier ist
von keiner veränderung also von keine
wirkung die eine ursache haben müsste
die rede
also wir fragen jedenfalls immer nach
dem grund mit der frage warum das ist
schon mal ganz wichtig
haben sie sonst noch etwas aus diesem
zitat entnommen was wichtig ist
als er scheint jetzt hier ganz unten das
auch noch interessant wenn es von
ursache wenn von ursache geräte ist
erscheint er hier auch immer die
veränderung mit dem spiel zu bringen
haben als man könnte sagen dass wir
grund von ursache unterscheiden müssen
das könnte jetzt hier schon so angelegt
sein
also dass ursache immer eine veränderung
verursachen muss sozusagen ja bewirken
muss und im dreieck das ist jetzt die
frage nach der logik müsste man sagen
das ist jetzt nicht mehr die frage nach
der tanz zentral logik erkannt auch in
der geometrie transzendentale strukturen
eine rolle spielen mit der eine raum die
reine anschauen des raums spielte auch
eine rolle
aber wenn wir jetzt in der logik fragen
warum sind in einem dreieck in diesem
dreieck die drei seiten gleich so wäre
die antwort weil die drei winkel gleich
sind es wäre als der grund aber nicht
die ursache
der grund er keine veränderung
hervorbringt im dreieck da bewegt sich
nichts da wird nichts verursacht dass
jetzt die drei winkel die drei seiten
verursachen bewegen man könnte sich
höchstens so vorstellen werden sie die
drei winkel annehmen also die drei
winzer setzen als grund dann ergibt sich
daraus gewissermaßen ergibt sich wenn
sie die linien dann weiterziehen
da ergeben sich dann so schnittpunkte an
da ergeben sich drei schnittpunkte wenn
sie drei winkel ansätzen in einem
dreieck und daneben 3 wickel bekommen
die frage ist ob man die linke beliebig
ansetzen kann das müsste mich mir jetzt
ein bisschen länger überlegen ob es egal
ist wie man die winkel ausrichtet
wahrscheinlich schon
dann bekommen sie eben diese drei
schnittpunkte und in diesem dreieck hat
da bekämen sie dann ein
aber dieses dreieck würde nicht mit
diesen drei gleich gleich langen seiten
aber diese drei gleich lang seiten
würden nicht durch die winkel
produzierte das so oder hervorgerufen
sie würden damit logisch einhergehen in
dem die winkel gesetzt sind sind 3
gleichheit und lang seiten logisch
gesetzt die folgen daraus nicht wie wenn
ich jetzt irgendwie etwas loslasse es
herunterfällt
kant denkt das ist allerdings noch ein
bisschen anders kann denkt tatsächlich
so dass wir jetzt nicht kausal oder so
aber kann denkt das so dass wir im
reinen raum in der reinen anschauen
sondern des reinraums das dreieck
zeichnen also wirklich eine linie ziehen
im idealen raum und der raum ist nichts
äußerliches und der raum ist uns so
denkt sich das kant wie auch die
arithmetik sich so vorstellt dass wir in
der reinen zeit in der logischen zeit
gewissermaßen dinge aufeinander
summieren als aufeinander legen und das
ist sehr kausal gedacht also denkt
tatsächlich geometrie in einem kausalen
sinne dass wir eine linie ziehen der
reinen anschauen form der zeit und das
ist natürlich mathematisch bestimmt
nicht korrekt und und logisch auch nicht
also ich glaube es eine gute
unterscheidung zu lesen ist das einfach
grund verursache unterscheiden möchte
bei ursache einfach bewegung bewegung
verrauscht oder veränderungen genommen
und der logik verändert sich nichts der
logik geht es um implikation
verhältnisse ist er etwas impliziert
wenn etwas impliziert ist dann ist es
nichts was bewirkt einen kausalen sinn
es wird vielleicht ne zitiert es wird
notwendig gemacht aber es wird nicht
verändert hervorgebrachten veränderung
wäre auch häufig etwas synthetisch und
jetzt kann man sich noch fragen bei
schopenhauer gibt der satz des zweiten
grund ist etwas synthetisches anders
etwas erkenntnis erweiterndes geschieht
oder ist es nicht doch etwas
analytisches dass wir also den satz von
zu reichen grunde die bedingung nur
genug analysieren müssen und dann zu
unserem ergebnis kommen und wenn das der
fall wäre dann wäre natürlich im sinne
einer synthetischen veränderung nicht
die rede ist sie bloß erkenntnis grund
nein denn die gleichheit der winkel ist
nicht bloß bestätigung der gleichheit
der zeiten nicht bloß grund eines
urteils aus bloßen begriffen ist ja gar
nicht einzusehen wie weil die weka
gleich sind auch die seiten gleich sein
müssen sagte also hier
es sei nicht analytisch denen begriffen
gleich hätte winkel nicht liegt nicht
der von gleichheit der seite habe ich so
meine zweifel so ein bisschen natürlich
im rein begrifflich gesehen nicht es ist
hier keine verbindung zwischen begriffen
oder urteilen sondern zwischenzeit und
winkeln die gleichheit der winkel ist
nicht unmittelbar grund zur erkenntnis
der gleichheit der seiten sondern
unmittelbar in dem sie grund des seins
hier das gleich science der seiten ist
darum dass die winkel gleich sind müssen
die seiten gleich sein
es findet sich hier eine notwendige
verbindung zwischen winkeln und zeiten
nicht unmittelbar eine notwendige
verbindung zweier urteile
wenn ich in einem anderen beispiel frage
warum tust du dies so wird mir irgendein
motiv angegeben wird dies eine ursache
sein auf welche die handlung als wirkung
gefolgt ist nein denn es kann mir kein
anderes angeben werden aus welchen die
handlung notwendig erfolgt die
verbindung zwischen ursache und wirkung
aber ist eine notwendige oder wird es
ein grund sein unter denen die handlung
als folge zu subsumieren ist nein denn
es ist nicht von einer erkenntnis
sondern von einer vorgegangen
veränderung geredet ja das ist jetzt
wieder etwas kompliziert was hier sagt
haben sie hier noch ein paar weitere
informationen herausnehmen können aus
diesem zitat ja
[Musik]
dann machte man sagt er unterscheidet
zwischen ursachen können die chemischen
industrie
aber es geht entscheidung der genug oder
noch andere irgendwann für das erste
beispiel angezeigte dem dreieck und es
scheint schon mal nicht weder die
ursachen aus ökologischen gründen zu
haben sondern mit dem matschigen und
hören und dann noch das andere beispiel
mit den handlungen selbst der welt
erklären kann zueinander regiert
dann sind jedes mal die notwendigkeit
steht sondern die nase vorne
jedes mal in rechner grund und die
wurzel des grundes genau können wir
vielleicht noch mal zusammenfassen was
diese vier wurzeln sind
sie haben schon ein paar genannt
veränderung veränderung das wäre
vielleicht zu dieser normale gewöhnliche
qualitätsbegriff causa effizienz mäßig
so ein bisschen vielleicht auch ein
freiheits grund das wollen ja ja muss
man noch mal schauen haben wir sonst
aber dann gibt es noch hier
dieses dreiecks diesen dreiecks grund
wie sommer denen es ist ein logischer
grund oder mathematischen gesagt
mathematischer grund
also sowas einfach mal vorläufig
mathematischen grund nennen und brauchen
noch einen vierten haben sie den auch
schon das wäre dann der logische grund
also das aus prämissen irgendwas folgt
also logik mathematik metaphysik das
wäre kausalität und handeln wollen
wenn also vier rede weiß von gründen
ständig eigentlich auch prima fazit
recht plausibel des problems eben immer
wenn man sagt es gibt vier gründe
da muss man beweisen dass es nicht mehr
sind und nicht weniger sind also das ist
vielleicht nicht weniger sind das liegt
nahe wenn man da unterscheidet aber ich
habe immer mit solchen thesen die jetzt
von der vierfachen wurzeln sprechen
probleme weil ich mich immer fragen
wieso gibt es nicht eine fünfte wurzeln
woher können wir beweisen erklären dass
es vollständig ist wie können wir die
vollständigkeit beweisen dass es nicht
noch ein fünfter oder sechster grund der
art von grund als sacken art von dessen
arten von gründen gibt ja wohl kommt es
gut hat es dann im bereich aufgezählt
was natürlich machen kann ist man kann
schauen wir schauen uns bisher alle
disziplinen der metaphysik an der
philosophie
dann finden wir es gibt logik es gibt
mathematik es gibt metaphysik oder
erkenntnistheorie man könnte auch noch
vielleicht seine erkenntnis grund aber
noch ein bisschen da reinbringen und wir
haben eben noch den freiheits grund wir
haben motive müsste man sagen also warum
tust du das er spricht hier von einem
motiv also das ist ein beweggrund
sozialen motiven
als privat scheint das schon sehr
also vollständig zu sein ok also das ist
mal interessant
spricht man muss natürlich noch mal
unterscheiden es gibt in der tradition
der philosophie gibt es den erkenntnis
grund und den science grund muss man
auch nochmal unterscheiden und bin mir
nicht ganz sicher ob schopenhauer die
hier sauber auseinander hält also also
wie sich jetzt diese vier gründe die er
da jetzt da an für die vier wurzeln oder
grund arten wie die sich wiederum zum
erkenntnis und science grund verhalten
also
ist wichtig aber jetzt bezogen auf diese
dieses zitat hier also man kann sich
jetzt fragen betreffen jetzt diese vier
wurzeln betreffend die jetzt sind
erkenntnis grund oder den science kommt
das meinte ich jetzt genau das müssen
wir jetzt erst noch offen lassen also
wir haben jetzt hier schon mal glaube
ich jetzt recht klar gesehen dass er von
verschiedenen arten von gründen spricht
und das ist durchaus gegenüber kant ein
fortschritt oder mal was neues weil kann
das so nicht machen
die gründe zu unterscheiden
und jetzt geht's mal weiter als wir
sehen aus den angeführten beispielen
dass nicht alle fälle in denen der satz
vom zureichenden grunde anwendung findet
sich zurückführen lassen aufgrund und
folge und ursache und wirkung
das also bei dieser einteilung gesetz
der spezifikation kein genüge geschehen
ist aber dem gesetz der homogenität
gemäss müssen wir voraussetzen dass die
fälle der anwendung der satzung zur eine
grunde nicht ins unendliche verschieden
sind sind dass sie alle auf gewisse
gattungen müssen zurückgeführt werden
können sich nun diese einteilung
versuche ist das nötigt bestimmt was dem
satz von zugleich den grund als sein
eigentümlicher charakter in allen fällen
eigens sei der geschlechts begriff muss
vor dem gattungsbegriff festgestellt
werden
halte das ist glaube ich auch ganz
verständlich wir müssen also jetzt
unterscheiden zwischen arten und
gattungen hier spricht er nochmal von
grund und folge und von ursache und
wirkung als grund und folge scheint mir
jetzt er sei die logische dimension zu
sein
sie widersprechen mir bitte und ursache
und wirkung ehrt die ontologische rede
zu sein
also das ist jetzt kausalität ursache
und wirkung und grund und folge ist er
die logische zb konklusion oder zu
lassen und jetzt muss sagt er wir müssen
dem gesetz der spezifikation wir müssen
also spezifizieren wir müssen den arten
und gattungen unterscheiden
und das will er jetzt hier also machen
aber davor wieder bestimmen was das der
eigentümlich charakter des grundes in
allen fällen als in alten ist sozusagen
der satz und sogar ein grund ist die
gattung geschrieben dass die oberste
ordnung und wir müssen jetzt erstmal
diesen charakter des der obersten
ordnung bestimmen und dann auch noch den
eigentümlichen charakter der
verschiedenen fälle oder arten so lese
ich das jetzt und er sagt der
geschlechts begriff muss aber das sind
also jetzt die muss vor dem
gattungsbegriff festgestellt werden wie
verstehen sie jetzt geschlechts begriff
und gattungsbegriff ist geschlechts
begriff höher als gattungsbegriff wohl
schon weil es nicht im singular ist ne
also es gibt mehrere gattungen einig
müsste man sagen art also so ein
bisschen habe ich ein bisschen problem
ist damit als eine müssen
es gibt dass die gattung und es gibt die
art der gattungsbegriff muss vor den art
begriffen festgestellt werden weil er
noch genereller ist es sagt jetzt aber
statt die stadt uns begriff sagte
geschlechts begriff und verrat start
begriff sagte gattungsbegriff so scheint
es mir jedenfalls nicht
es gibt also eine gattung und es gibt
verschiedene arten und typen von sätzen
von von gründen von unterscheidung so
wie es jetzt gemacht haben
ok und jetzt kommt er hier also mehr
darauf zu sprechen er sagt unser
bewusstsein so weit ist als sinnlichkeit
verstand und vernunft erscheint zerfällt
in subjekt und objekt und enthält bis
dahin nichts außer dem objekt für das
objekt sein und unsere vorstellung sein
ist das selbe alle unsere vorstellungen
sind objekte des subjekts und alle
objekte des subjekts sind unsere
vorstellung
aber nichts für sich bestehen des und
unabhängiges auch nichts einzelne sind
abgerissenes kann objekt für uns werden
sind alle unsere vorstellungen stehen
einer gesetzmäßigen und der form nach
apriori bestimmbaren verbindung
diese verbindung ist diejenige art der
relation welche der satzung zur
eichengrund allgemein genommen ausdrückt
jenes über alle unsere vorstellung
herrschendes gesetz ist die wurzel des
unzureichenden grunde selbiges ist
tatsache und der satz zu reichen grunde
ist sein ausdruck allgemein aber wie es
hier aufgestellt ist können wir es nur
durch abstraktion gewinnen gegeben ist
es uns allein durch fälle im konkreten
also ganz wichtig ist hier dieser satz
jenes über alle unsere vorstellung
herrschende gesetz ist die wurzel des
vom zweiten runde
und es ist uns nur im konkreten gegeben
wie verstehen sie das das ist uns nur im
konkreten gegeben ist wie verstehen sie
das
also
das ist leseförderung der spieler selbst
ich glaube die überhaupt nicht zu müssen
noch mit
wiedersehen
sollte es also etwas gedacht wird
technischen regeln regeln des denkens
voll und dann haben wir richtig bei
einem denkt muss man also keinen
komponiert des traktes denken
niemand etwas also willkommen
und das was dann gedacht dass bei gilt
es dann natürlich über sonst aber die
machen wir selber ist die aktion das
prinzip letztendlich oder auch der grund
des grundes könnte sagt es ist ganz
interessant ist der grund der grund dass
überhaupt etwas ein grund haben kann
können könnte vielleicht sei ein grund
zweiter ordnung das ist jetzt aber ein
bisschen von mir hineininterpretiert
größtenteils größtenteils er will eben
mehr noch als es kann tut zwischen
gründen unterscheiden kann spricht vom
grund nicht so sehr kann spricht kant
hat kein also gut kann spricht zum
beispiel von einer ratio cognos 10 die
oder der asl die an manchen stellen aber
dann auch nur eine fußnote in der kritik
der praktischen vernunft eine vom
sittengesetz spricht aber eine
eigentliche analyse des grundes gibt es
bei kann so nicht also kann spricht ganz
prominent von kausalität von ursachen
wirkungen aber so einen generellen grund
des ganzen nochmal anzugehen das ist
jenseits von tanzprojekte trans mental
viel zu viel
der grund wäre sozusagen noch mal die
letzte rahmung die noch mal über das ich
hinaus geht nach schopenhauer
wir haben ganz verschiedene rahmen
gehabt wir haben ist dieses sinnes daten
gehabt dann haben wir substanzen zu
haben raum und zeit und am ende haben
wir dieses trends and eilig und nach
schopenhauer müssten wir dann
wahrscheinlich um dieses ich noch meinen
letzten möglichen rahmen ziehen und der
wäre eben der satz von gründen oder
dass er schon mit kranken
kampf finalrennen haben wir
die kausalität ein rahmen der satzung
runde beieinander dass die welt
wahrscheinlich sinnliches aus diesen
beiden zusammen
so könnte man es auch sagen ja oder er
würde ihn könnte schon sagen es gibt
kaum sanität aber es wäre eben nicht der
letzte grund sind es gibt eben dann
nochmal eine wurzel davon
ja das ist ja heute noch mal zurück auf
die frage wir haben natürlich bei kant
auch verschiedene arten von gründen oder
von kausalität das hat mir gesehen
werden gesehen es gibt also nach kant
sowas wie ereignis kausalität das ist
also wirklichkeit und wir haben so etwas
wie akteurs kausalität das haben das
letzte mal gesehen akteurs kausalität
wäre es so was wie bei schopenhauer hier
das motiv ist motiv obwohl wie sie schon
sagten dass bei schopenhauer nicht so
klar ist ob er von der freiheit des
menschlichen willens ausgeht
es gibt da verschiedene lesen arten ich
lese ihnen auch als und handlungs also
theoretisch ihre handlungsfreiheit schob
man sagt wir sind handlungsfreiheit wir
willens reich sind wir unser wollen
selbst bestimmen können daher gibt es
offene debatten darüber
viele sagen nein er bestreitet
willensfreiheit kannte ist ein ganz
großer befürworter der willensfreiheit
ohne frage also auf ihre frage zurück
erkannt würde durchaus verschiedene
arten von gründern kennen oder von
kausalität nämlich 2 und dann würde sich
schopenhauer fragen auch wenn das jetzt
hier nicht so explizit worin oder
vielleicht auch noch würde kanten
logischen grund noch kein schopenhauer
wurde fragen worin besteht der grund für
diese verschiedene gründe
es muss doch ein einheits grund dieser
verschiedenen arten von kausalität geben
zwischenstation wichtig weil es einige
zeit alle uns wohl schwere objekte des
ok und alle objekte das sind unsere
vorstellungen
man schlägt der schweizer auch drin sein
das auge fällt
auf jeden fall das richtige wäre also
heidelbeeren ontologische abfrage
objekte sind uns sie sind nicht wenn die
police werden
die vorstellungen aller europäer setzen
unsere vorstellungen das heißt das
subjekt setzt sich absolut das ist das
absolute pflicht ist und die wir alles
politisch stark und auch unsere
unsere vorstellung außerhalb
[Musik]
also das ist eine große frage inwiefern
neben schopenhauer auch noch sich mit
fichte beschäftigt hat es liegt auf der
hand als sie herr zeller professor
zeller argumentiert immer dafür dass
richtet eine große rolle gespielt hat es
ist jedenfalls auffällig dass
schopenhauer jetzt nicht direkt kant nur
um ein rädchen weiterdreht sind er dreht
kann um einiges weiter und das passt
insofern mit einigen anderen philosophen
des deutschen tourismus wie zum beispiel
johann gottlieb fichte zusammen also
würde zugeben dass es da eine gewisse
ähnlichkeit gibt es dieser idealismus
ist noch stärker ausgeprägt
aber dieser idealismus den kann man
wieder zurückführen auf den versuch ganz
philosophie weiter zu fundieren oder
noch einheitlicher darzustellen insofern
teilen die ganzen nach kantischen denke
dasselbe interesse sie wollen irgendwie
an kant anknüpfen aber an irgendeinem
grund ist er ihn nicht befriedigend
genug meistens ist es der einheits grund
kann spricht da von einer einheit er
spricht von zwei stimmen der erkenntnis
kann man sich fragen warum sonst in zwei
ställen mit erkenntnis kann man nicht
alles auf einen stamm der erkenntnis
zurück bin also von dieser
herangehensweise sind schopenhauer und
fichte sich sicherlich recht ähnlich ich
weiß jetzt allerdings nichts näheres wie
genau die fichte rezeption von
schopenhauer ausgesehen hatte
schopenhauer einfach so viele sachen
rezipiert hat und alles zusammen
integriert hat doch die werden also als
indische hat der verwandte gehabt die
eben da auch geforscht hatten also hat
er zurückgegriffen auf alle möglichen
quellen das wäre eine detail arbeit die
man am anderen ort leisten könnte aber
hinsichtlich des grund an diesen nach
kantischen philosophen ist sicherlich
nie gegeben zu fürchten
und jetzt geht es um diese vierfach hyde
jetzt geht es also um die frage warum
diese wurzel gerade 4 vs besagte fälle
in denen sich das gesetz den notwendigen
verknüpfung all unserer vorstellung
offenbart und in denen folglich der satz
von zureichenden grunde als ausdruck
derselben anwendung findet sondern sich
bei näherer den gesetzen der homogenität
und der spezifikation gemäss angestellt
und betrachtung in bestimmte voneinander
sehr verschiedene gattungen von deren
anzahl ich behaupte dass ich vier sei
und sich richtig nach den vier klassen
in welch alles was für uns objekt werden
kann das heißt alle unsere vorstellung
zerfallen
diese klassen werden in den nächsten
vier kapitel aufgestellt und abgehandelt
seit kans der diktion der kategorien
gibt es aber fast nichts zur
ursprüngliches und unmittelbares dass es
nicht wäre apriori de doziert worden
sogar dingen zu deren gründe
hinaufzusteigen keine frühere zeit
gehofft hatte dingen geschah was goethe
sagt der philosoph der tritt herein und
beweist euch es muss so sein
woher ist dieses zitat
wo aus sich im werk ist dieses zitat
wissen sie das ist ja das ist natürlich
das ist natürlich der faust
genau das ist ein fehlschluss von
schopenhauer zu sagen dass wenn eine
figur ist irgendwas sagt dass das jetzt
goethe sagen würden bis zum schluss vom
auf den autor der fehlschluss
naja das ist eine große debatte
ok also was können wir jetzt hier noch
daraus mitnehmen
also er sagt es gibt fälle und zwar wohl
das sind die arten in denen das gesetz
notwendig verknüpfung und das ist wohl
das des gesetzes hat zureichende grundes
die notwendige verknüpfung unserer
vorstellung und wir sind ein ausdruck
diese fälle die verschiedenen gründe
sind ausdruck derselben also man könnte
sagen es sind keine unabhängigen
vorkommnisse diese vier gründe vom
satzes zureichend grund ist oder von
diesem prinzip müsste man allerdings sei
es im prinzip sondern sie sind ausdrücke
als sind manifestationen also wie der
wille sich nach schopenhauer
manifestiert in verschiedenen weißen
dann der wille manifestiert sich nach
schopenhauer einzel dingen also in
organismen im leben verschiedene
lebensformen aber sie sind letztendlich
alles lebendige ist nach schopenhauer
der ausdruck dass einen willen muss so
könnte man sich auch über denken dass
alles was geschieht oder ein grund hat
welcher grund auch immer ein ausdruck
dieses prinzips ist jetzt wäre natürlich
spannend das jetzt wiederum auf den
willens begriff zu beziehen
welche formen oder ausdrücke des grundes
jetzt auf den willen anzuwenden sind
sicherlich diejenigen der motive das ist
ganz klar die logik wohl eher nicht als
der grund der logik der wird nicht in
villen gefunden werden kann ihm
erscheint an die logik scheint so mir
jedenfalls jetzt nichts zu sein was über
den willens begriff erklärt werden kann
die lobby ist was fast food
hilfen unabhängig ist jedenfalls scheint
mir wichtig dass es also ein ausdruck
des helden ist ein ausdruck schon zu
kämpfen getötet und unser sie fordern
als motzki wir irgendwo hier selten
und 4
würde
noch dreimal glück ist das leben als
solches in frage gestellt weil ohne
entsprechende behandlung spot nicht mehr
aufstehen
formal logisch richtig man müsste jetzt
höchstens noch fragen ist jetzt ein
bisschen speck
man müsste jetzt das ist interessanter
gedanke man könne jetzt vor spinnen man
müsste sich dann frage ob mit diesem
ziel diese aufregung nicht auch noch
eine weitere form der kausalität an
betreuung des grundes betroffen wäre
nämlich die wirklichkeit schlechthin das
als die wirklichkeit als ursache und
wirkung ob die dann in diesem zustand
diesem idealzustand nicht auch
aufgehoben ist dass ich da gar nichts
mehr verändern nicht nur unser motiv
isches wollen sondern überhaupt das
wirkt kausale also verhalten der welt
nennen aber das ist eine weiterführende
fragen spekulative frage also hier ist
noch mal wichtig sei konstruktion der
kategorien also kann versucht und das
gesteht jetzt schopenhauer ihm zu alle
bestandteile der trans zentralen logik
also alle verstandes begriffe substanz
kausalität die trans and arlen logik
betreffen die versucht kant zu
reduzieren also doch gewissermaßen aus
einem gemeinsamen grund her zu meiden
und dieser gemeinsame grund oder das
vehikel um dieses transportmedium aus
dem diese ganzen kategorien sich
entfalten ist nach kant das trans
zentrale ich dieses ich denke dass es
nach kant der oberste grund diese ganzen
kategorien des verstandes
also das ist diese reduktion der
kategorien und
da sieht also schopenhauer mal wieder
bei kann zum vorbild das etwas zurück
flug auf ein grund schopenhauer möchte
aber doch noch einen entscheidenden
schritt weiter gehen und er nennt das
das hinaufsteigen zu den gründen als er
möchte und es ist ein philosophisches
anliegen wie wir auch schon bei platon
in seinem höhlengleichnis sehen das
aufsteigen zu den gründen
das ist das höhlengleichnis und in
verbindung damit auch das sonnen
gleichnis wir müssen immer zu dem
prinzip hingelangt ist im prinzip der
viel halten und das unternehmen kann
jedenfalls bei der reduktion der
kategorien dass ich denke ist der
oberste punkt an dem alle kategorien
aufgehängt sind ist der einheits grund
der kategorien und schopenhauer möchte
das jetzt noch genereller machen mit dem
satz des zu reichen gründe
daher möchte mancher erwarten dass auch
ich jetzt nicht mangelte durch eine
reduktion apriori um eine berechtigung
zu jener einteilung da zu tun
allein ich gestehen dass ich die
möglichkeit eine reduktion apriori der
vier klassen von vorstellungen welche
uns allein gegeben sind nicht einsehen
zwar könnte ich das ungeachtet als
vogelscheuche gegen zweifler eine win
aufgrund und gehalt lose doch wenigstens
durch ihre langweiligkeit furchtbare
reduktion aufstellen
aber ich fürchte dass er dadurch an die
aufgeblasenen schläuche zu erinnern
welche dem abo leos als er nachts zu
tunken zu hause kam vor die haustüre
gehängt waren damit er sie in dem der
wind ihnen bewegung gab für räuber hielt
die ins haus brechen wollte daher gründe
ich meine einteilung aller unserer
vorstände auf induktion
die keines anderen beweises fähig ist
als der aufforderung irgendein objekt zu
finden das unter kein der vier
aufgestellten klassen gehörte oder
zweifeln diesen als nur eine ausmachen
darzustellen das ist jetzt noch mal
dieses problem was ich vorhin benannt
hatte vollständigkeit
schopenhauer muss einen grund dafür
geben dass es genau vier manifestation
oder vier ausformung oder für arte
dieser gattung dieses grundes als
solchen gibt und das zu tun also diese
vollständigkeit aufzuweisen und zu
begründen dass ein schopenhauer in
ausgang von cannes dem anknüpfen an kant
eine reduktion eine detektion reduktion
meint auch immer so was wie eine
rechtfertigung also eine begründung
warum ist es gerade so nicht so kann
macht es bei den kategorien gibt es
verstand ist also kausalität
substantially tät und sofort das erkannt
ich kann beweisen dass es genauso viele
sind und nicht mehr und dass sie sich
genauso verhalten ihrer logik und kann
trifft dagegen aristoteles vor dass
aristoteles diese kategorien nur
rhapsodisch aufgezählt habe also
willkürlich sie kennen diese kategorien
schrift bei aristoteles gibt es auch die
hexe die lage
und so weiter und so fort ganz
verschiedene folien person also wie viel
und so weiter und so fort vielheit
einheit da sagt jetzt aber kant
aristoteles hat diese ganzen kategorie
nur ganz beliebig einfach so auf gezählt
wie sie ihm so gerade kam dagegen möchte
kann zeigen dass die ganze kategorien an
einer bestimmten logik gehorchen und
dasselbe möchte jetzt wiederum
schopenhauer mit kant machen so ein
bisschen diese atmen auch wenn er kann
natürlich zu gesteht dass er mit seiner
reduktion schon sehr viel erreicht hat
aber wie möchte es jetzt nicht machen
also möchte jetzt nicht eine typische
reduktion erst mal anstrengend sondern
dass der letzte satz daher gründe ich
meine
abteilung auf induktion die keines
anderen beweis es fähig ist als der
aufforderung irgendein objekt zu finden
das unter keine der vier aufgestellten
tassen gehört oder zweifeln dienen als
nur eine ausmachen darzustellen als er
sagt ja dann zeigt mir doch mal hier ihr
müsst es mir zeigen
also es hat sich einfach bewährt
empirisch hier müssen wir jetzt zeigen
dass eine art dieser 4
vielleicht entweder zurückzuführen ist
auch eine andere dieser 4
und hätten wir nur drei oder dass sie
eben noch eine weitere findet er möchte
nicht der duc thi vorgehen sondern
induktiv ist eigentlich ganz schlau weil
er eben dann auch dem zirkel nicht
verfallen wird also wenn ich jetzt sagen
würde ich möchte das depot zieren dann
müsste er sozusagen eigentlich schon
partiell damit voraussetzen was er
gerade beweisen möchte und kommt denn
diesen zirkel des reisens rein
also man kann den satz es zu einem grund
ist deswegen nicht reduzieren weil er
eben immer auf gründe angewiesen werden
man könnte also sagen schopenhauer zeigt
hier dass es so ein unhintergehbaren
grund gibt also die bedingung der
möglichkeit von beweisen und die kann
ich selbst nicht wiederum beweisen weil
es hier der grund überhaupt färbe weise
ist es hat also der grund hat also
vielleicht könnte man sagen eine art
trans zentralen status und deswegen
sagte müssen wir anders vorgehen wir
müssen eher induktiv vorgehen und uns
durch erfahrung durch sichtung aller
möglichen art von gründe entweder eines
besseren belehren lassen oder aber nicht
also
antworten erst seit 2
und bei
erweitert tief unten
es war hand gute frage geht an das
plenum warum sollten wir jetzt gerade
mehr gründe annehmen wollen
ich mein man muss dazusagen erstmals 1
grunderkenntnis grund sind jetzt nicht
diese vier wurzeln
mit praktischen
gute frage da geht es mir
zwei regeln des gewissens
die spezifikation also quasi so wenig
wie möglich aber so viel wie fühlt sich
darauf sich das schon also der brücke
zwischen dreieck dass er doch nicht von
den beiden gegeben und er hält aber
trotzdem
das heißt kein fall für die
spezifikation erweitern ist und das ist
sie müssen einfach mehr mit dem ball
gemacht werden und überhaupt ist für den
wir müssen einfach wie zb das 3 das
zeigt nicht nur oder sehr kleiner trend
ist du hast mich am anfang des ersten
teils aber das ist auch schon fusionen
in der moskauer u bahn hat ein objekt
und das hat es dass das alles notwendig
dass das kein argument ist es einfach
und dann habe ich
erfolglos
könnte man so sehen ja
dass man so weit von der wahrheit der
aussage ist die seite nicht gefunden
entspricht somit unerwartet aussagen
und der möchte eben das ist der
unterschied zu sagen es ist wahr dass
beide seiten andere ausweichen also die
wahl ist die gerechtigkeit dass dieses
objekt
das ist ein sehr guter punkt ist ein
sehr guter punkt punkt weiß jetzt genau
sie haben nämlich jetzt auch sie haben
jetzt auch die asymmetrie der kausalität
relation hingewiesen also die kausalität
relation ist asymmetrisch
ich kann es nicht umdrehen also die
wirkung ist nicht die ursache
sozusagen der ursache ich kann sich
umdrehen und beim mathematischen
verhältnissen war zumindest von winkeln
und seiten kann ich's da kann ich sagen
die drei seiten sind leicht lang seiten
sind der grund für die drei gleich
großen winkel und umgedreht da gilt es
also beide male im grunde das heißt da
haben wir dann eine symmetrie da haben
wir eine logische symmetrie bei
kausalität haben wir keine keine
symmetrie sondern asymmetrie das heißt
das wer so ein spezifischer grund geben
wenn jetzt eine weitere art anzusetzen
einfach aus aus solchen logischen
verhältnissen heraushören
neben auch ehrlich und der komposition
die frühesten schließen
das ist also wie könnte man dann diese
art von grund nennen beim dreieck haben
sie einen vorschlag mathematische gründe
geometrische gründe
man kann natürlich immer bei bei deshalb
vielleicht auch so ein punkt bei drei
ecken könnte man natürlich immer sagen
wir beziehen uns hier natürlich auf die
aktion
die eu- kritischen aktionen das ist
natürlich auch noch st also welche rolle
spielen dabei die athletischen axiome
reduzieren wir nicht irgendwie aus den
politischen aktion etwas auch im sinne
von grund und folge dass die gelben
seiten
als ein analytischer und analytischer
satzung würde schon ein bisschen
verstehen
dass wir sind natürlich kann man das so
man kann man das so sehen
man habe also weit ist es manchmal
schrecklich
da war jetzt auch eine meldung da
ausgeschlossen
jetzt 90
für eine art
das ist ein zeichen und der spanischen
vorstellt
zweiter klasse die begriffe aus diesem
raum und zeit und vierten klasse sind
ist es so viel wie nach dem start sicher
der salz-
und dieses zeichen zur hilfe vorstellen
und das hat seinen grund ist gegen
phelps vom thron des erkenntnisses und
da ja heißt in einem unfall
das ausdrücken sollen zeit zu reden
warum wird zurzeit gebaut zeitraum zeit
vielleicht sogar noch den pokal und ein
zauber des landes über kuppen und zu
verstehen weshalb dieses geschlossen
[Musik]
und da wäre er dann wieder sehr nahe bei
kant dran erkannt eben auch geometrie
mit raum in verbindung gesetzt und
arithmetik mit zeit das ist ganz
interessant waren jetzt leser mal weiter
ich bin merke beiläufig dass selbst kann
es aufzählung der kategorien sich
zuletzt auf induktion gründet sie ist
nämlich der logischen tafel der urteile
gemäss abgefasst und die einteilung der
beschaffenheit dieser in vier gattungen
deren jede drei arten begreift ist
einzig auf induktion bekommt etwas kann
selbst bezeichnet in dem er bei
aufstellung derselben sagte tat wenn wir
auf die bloße verstandes formen den
urteilen acht geben
so finden wir dass die funktionen des
denkens unter vier titel gebracht werden
können und eben da selbst sagt er
von der eigentümlichkeit unseres
verstandes nur vermittelte kategorien
und gerade nur durch diese art und zahl
der selben einheit der perzeption
apriori zustande zu bringen lässt sich
ebenso wenig ferner ein grund angeben
als warum wir gerade diese und keine
anderen funktionen zu urteilen haben
oder warum zeit und raum die einzigen
formen unsere möglichen anschauungs sind
was aber seine reduktion der kategorien
betrifft so ist sie keineswegs eine
demonstration dass es solche und gerade
so viele kategorien geben müssen sondern
die erklärung der art wie sich begriffe
a priori auf gegenstände beziehen können
also schopenhauer möchte jetzt hier in
diesem zitat sagen dass seine methode
der induktion der vollständig des
nachweis der vollständigkeit der arten
selbst bei kann schon zu finden sein
das also kant selbst induktiv eigentlich
vorgeht warum weil er nämlich schaut wie
wir urteilen als er schaut welche arten
von urteilen es gibt und das ist eher
eine induktive weiß reduziert nicht wie
welche arten von urteilen es gibt sind
reduziert von den arzt an der urteile
wie wir sie fehlen die vollständigkeit
der kategorien aber das hängt davon ab
wer nicht recht verstehen wie viele
formen von urteilen wir und welche wie
viele funktionen verurteilen wir
vollziehen können und das wäre nach oben
habe wie der induktive art und weise
also bekannt ließ sozusagen unserem
alltäglichen sprachgebrauch und zum
urteils gebrauch ab wie viele funktionen
es geben kann also wie viele kategorien
es gehen kann
für die gegenwärtige einteilung der für
das objekt möglichen objekte ist demnach
eine reduktion nicht nur nicht nötig
sondern sogar würde die forderung
derselben ohne sinn und bedeutung seien
jene einteilung ist wie gesagt einzig
auf induktion gegründet in jeder der nur
mehr aufzustellen den vier klassen von
gegenständen unseres
vorstellungsvermögens tritt der satz vom
zur eichengrund in einer anderen gestalt
auf gibt sich aber überall dadurch dass
er den oben angegebenen ausdruck zulässt
nämlich der satz von zwei gründe als
derselbe zu erkennen und als aus der
paragraf 17 angegebenen wurzeln
entsprossen deren vierfach haid geben
aus jenen vier gestaltung erhält bei
aufstellung jeder klasse von vorstellung
werde ich zugleich diejenige gestaltung
des satz 15 grunde aufzeigen die als
gesetzt der verbindung darin herrscht ja
also das ist glaube ich hier nochmal ein
guter überblick
also die mit der methode wir eben
vorgehen möchte und jetzt kommt es zur
ersten klasse
die erste klasse der möglichen
gegenstände unseres
vorstellungsvermögens ist die der
vollständigen das ganze eine erfahrung
aus machen den vorstellungen der satz
vom zu reichen grunde herrscht in ihr
als gesetz der kausalität von weiter
unten mehr die rede sein wird
die zu dieser klasse gehörigen
vorstellungen sind vollständige dies
bezieht sich auf ganz einteilung und
heißt sie begreifen sowohl das material
als das formale der sinnlichen
erscheinen
sie machen ein ganzes der erfahrung aus
heißt sie stehen in einem durch den
verstand allein erkennbaren zusammenhang
sie beschäftigen also unsere ganze
sinnlichkeit und unseren ganzen verstand
sie sind was die objektive reale welt
genannt wird bleiben wir mal also bei
dieser ersten klasse der vorstellung
das ist also ein möglicher
anwendungsfall des funk zu reichen kunde
und wie manifestiert sich nochmal dieser
satz von zu reichen gründe hier solide
ganzen erfahrung
sagte hier auch in der dritten in der
vierten zeile als gesetz der kausalität
wie kann man sich das vorstellen
inwiefern hängt die kausalität als eine
form deshalb an alt als ein ausprägung
der satz schon zu weit im grunde wie
hängt diese mit der vollständigen
erfahrung unserer vorstellung zusammen
die jungen vorbehalten
was auch kam dass ein journalist bei der
qualität so nicht ist und ob die klausel
denken sondern ob diese qualität
notwendig ist und er löst das problem
indem er sagt positiv ist nicht fremd
ist eine form der notwendigkeit und so2
bedient wenn ich wirklich auch dinge
drin die vorstellung letztendlich so
dass wir die notwendigkeit nicht aus den
erscheinen sondern dessen guter punkt
also aber noch einmal kurz zurück auf
die vollständigkeit es geht immer um die
vollständigkeit der erfahrung das sagt
ja auch kann also kann sagt wir können
nur dann erfahrungen machen überhaupt
nur erfahrung machen wenn die erfahrung
vollständig ist also sprich wenn es
keine lücken gibt in der rvs könnte ja
sein dass ich eine zeit lang erfahrung
mache und plötzlich habe ich dann eine
lücke
sprich ich hab jetzt vorstellung oder
wahrnehmungen die sich gar nicht mehr in
einer gewissen ordnung zeiten also
sprich wahrnehmung die sich nicht mehr
pauschal verstehen lassen wo ich zum
beispiel gar kein grund angeben kann
dafür zb wunder wäre nach kanzlers ein
wunder wenn da jetzt irgend wie ein
wunder passiert dass ich nicht mit der
naturwissenschaft erklären ist dann
würde das bedeuten dass jeder satz vom
zur gleichen grunde danach kannte das
qualitäts prinzip nicht anwendung fahren
würde und dann wäre das nach kant keine
vollständige erfahrung mehr wäre
sozusagen im erfahrungs kontext einen
locker drin wäre unser erfahrungs
kontext zerstört worden einer stelle als
ganz wichtig ist verkannt und da knüpft
jetzt schon mauer an ihn
die vollständigkeit erfahrung also alles
muss miteinander in einer beziehung
stehen und zwar in einer beziehung der
begründetheit und deswegen ist verkannt
zumindest des kausalität prinzip so
wichtig weil es uns überhaupt erst
erfahrungen machen lässt und erfahrung
ist immer vollständige erfahrung also es
gibt kein phänomen weiß ich nicht kausal
beschreiben dies das bedeutet verkannt
die vollständigkeit jetzt endlich ne und
jetzt sagen sie bezogen auf die jugend
suchte die notwendigkeit dieser
vollständigkeit in der erfahrung selbst
und er konnte sie dort nicht finden
beziehungsweise nur induktiv dorthin
gelangt ist übrigens auch interessant
dass jetzt schopenhauer auch eine
induktivität zugrunde legt aber nicht
auf die gegenstands ebene sind auf der
metaebene also auf der ebene der
prinzipien legt schopenhauer einen
induktions prinzip zugrunde aber nicht
mehr auf der ebene der objekte die mit
dem prinzip erklärt werden
david hume hatte es so gemacht er hat
das induktions prinzip angenommen auf
der ebene der objekte der brahms objekt
er konnte es da natürlich nicht finden
und jetzt würde er praktisch gegenüber
kant sagen
schopenhauer also kannte ich gebe dir
recht die notwendigkeit und die
verbindlichkeit der erfahrung die
kriegen wir nicht aus der erfahrung
selbst die verbindlichkeit ist die
bedingung der möglichkeit von von
erfahrung von kohärente erfahrung dann
aber er würde gegen cantz sagen wir
finden sie auch nicht in letzter
hinsicht im kausalität prinzip was uns
im verstand gründet sondern wir müssen
eigentlich noch einen schritt weiter
gehen nämlich aufwind grund dieses
qualitätsprodukt haben diese wurzeln
des satzes von zureichende grunde also
die kausalität muss noch mal tiefer
gelegt werden sozusagen bei schuhbauer
zurückgeführt werden als ein ast oder
antrieb oder eine wurzel strang dieses
ursprünglichen prinzips also er bestimmt
kante zu versucht aber nochmal eine
ebene tiefer das ganze in angriff zu
nehmen kann nur sagen es ist einfach
eine eintrieb also ein ausprägung dieses
grundsätzliche prinzip noch mal zurück
gefragt wie bestimmt denn jetzt
schopenhauer nochmal dieses wissen
diesen satz von zugänglichen
grundprinzipien wie kann denn das jetzt
hier nochmal kurz begründen
worin besteht diese grund ganz allgemein
gesagt
haben sie denn noch mal eine idee ja
aber damit dass er während die frage ob
das nicht schon zu spezifisch ist diese
redeweise weil sie jetzt ja von bewirbt
sprechen also das schon so etwas wie
kausalität zu grunde zu legen scheint
kann man das vielleicht noch ein
bisschen grundsätzlicher darstellt
genau genau das ist also ganz ähnlich
nur sie haben jetzt gesagt bewirkt und
verändert glaube ich auch dass sich
verändert haben sie nicht gesagt aber
bewirkt haben sie gesagt und da wäre
dann veränderungen drin und da würde
dein schopenhauer sagen
bei dem mathematischen dreieck wird eben
nichts verändert also wenn ich eben die
drei winkel drei gleich große winkel
ansätze und die der grund für die drei
gleich langen seiten sind dann werden
die nicht dadurch verändert also es wird
nichts hervorgebracht sondern ist es
einfach eine erklärung
genau ich glaube in paragraph 16 sagte
das also nichts ist ohne grund § 16 das
glaube ich also nichts ist ohne grund
das ist dieser satzung zur eichengrund
ist oder alles hat einen grund oder
alles braucht einen grund um überhaupt
zu sein
auch schon vorher auch schon vorher ganz
ganz wohl
da kann man bestimmt auch schon auf die
vorzeitige zurückgehen also es gibt es
gibt bayern als solcher parmenides gibt
es ja dieses ist ist und nicht ist ist
nicht passiert sich genau dasselbe aber
das ist ein so tief greifendes prinzip
dieser satzung zu grunde dass die
philosophie von anbeginn an beschäftigt
hat bei leibnitz natürlich ganz klar bei
platon natürlich auch die idee des guten
die ist seins und erkenntnis grund
zugleich also in der idee des guten
haben wir bei platon auch schon so eine
wurzel aber nur zweifache wurzeln
erkenntnis grund uns science grund und
schon im haushalt nein wir müssen vier
wurzeln ansetzt
als ich hier geht dann noch mal hin das
ist also diese sache
die hat sie noch selber über den
ursprung und sagt dass ein eben solcher
schon vorplanung herbeizitiert plan
gescheitert
es ist notwendig dass alles was
geschieht ist eine ursache könnte
dieses geschieht genau das ist jetzt
alles nach platonische aber ich vermute
wir finden einen vorsichtigen schon so
war zum beispiel das weiß ich sicher es
gibt ja dann bei den versorgern theorien
die sagen alles ist aus einem atom
entstanden
ja oder es gibt diese theorie dass alles
aus den vier elementen entstanden ist
feuer wasser erde luft und diese vier
elemente lehre ist praktisch schon so
eine art nicht direkten vorläufer dieses
dieser verwurzeln weil die dass er
natürlich nicht mehr auf einen einheits
grund zurückführen diese vier elemente
aber dieses spekulative denken dieses
rein heizdecken das gibt solange es
philosophie gibt es gibt es alles in
allem tradition
ok also damit haben wir jetzt hier das
wichtigste erst mal besprochen
wir werden in der nächsten sitzung noch
mal ein bisschen ausführlicher auf die
anderen wurzeln eingehen wir haben jetzt
nur eine wurzel jetzt hier bezogen sage
jetzt mal den job machen eine wurzel
gezogen wir wollen eben noch drei
weitere wurzeln ziehen die dann eben
auch die nicht nur die kausalität grund
relation betrifft sanieren das wovon er
sprachlich geometrischen szene aber auch
noch das wollen und die logik diese
wurzeln wollen wir auch noch mal ganz
kurz offenlegen freilegen auch wenn es
dann schon mal wehtun könnte und
kritisch analysieren und dann gehen wir
in der nächsten sitzung meines wissens
zu hans reichenbach über seine
populistische qualitätsziele